Hello, and welcome to Unreal Training, Stage Operations,
Configuration, and Initialization.
My name is Kevin Miller.
I'm one of three instructors that
is going to walk you through our Stage Operations course.
The Stage Operations courses have several stations
that we set up for hands-on users
to actually spend time working on the projects
and applying things that they've learned
in the previous courses.
In this course, we will be breaking up
to different sections for your hands-on training stations.
We'll begin with an LED volume hardware and processing
station led by Brian Pohl, who will take you
through the setup and assembly of the camera
and a look at our hardware for the LED volume.
Next, Sean Spitzer and I will do a demo of replacing
the LED panel on the wall.
After that, I will walk you through a hands-on for end
display configuration and setup,
and then finish up with a switchboard setup and launch.
Finally, Sean Spitzer will take you
through a color profile implementation for OCIO
and 3D LUTs.
After that, we'll show you a review of the stage pre-flight
checklist, and then you can apply these on your own
in your stage situations.